so we have an interesting circuit here
the goal of this video is to figure out
what is the current that flows through
the 6 ohm resistor pause this video and
see if you can work through it
so the way that i am going to tackle it
is first simplify the circuit take these
two resistors in parallel and think
about what the equivalent resistance
would be
and we have seen that before
1 over the equivalent resistance is
going to be equal to 1 over 6.0 ohms
plus 1 over 12.0 ohms
1 6 is the same thing as 2 over 12.
so 2 12 plus 1 12 is 3 12
and 3 12 you could view that as the same
thing as 1 over 4.0 ohms and so 1 over
the equivalent resistance is equal to 1
over 4 ohms well that means that the
equivalent resistance is 4 ohms and so
we can simplify our circuit now where we
replace these two resistors in parallel
with one resistor of the equivalent
resistance and that is going to be equal
to a 4 ohm resistor
now the next thing we could do is we
could figure out what the current is
through this part of the circuit which
would be the same thing as the current
right over there we could call that i
sub 1
and we can just use ohm's law for that
we would have i sub 1
would be equal to our voltage drop which
is 24 volts
24 volts
divided by the
equivalent resistance of these two
resistors in series and when you have
resistors in series you just add them up
to figure out the equivalent resistance
so this would be divided by 2.0 ohms
plus 4 ohms
plus 4.0 ohms 24 divided by 2 plus 4 or
24 divided by 6 is 4 and since we're
dealing with two significant digits
it'll be 4.0 and we're talking about
current so this is 4.0 amps or 4.0
amperes now how do we use that
information to calculate this current
right over here we can call that i sub
2.
now one way to think about it is what is
going to be your voltage drop from this
point to this point if you know the
voltage drop from that point to that
point and if you know that the voltage
drop from this point all the way down
here is then we can figure out what the
voltage drop from here to here is going
to be so let's do that so the voltage
drop across this first resistor remember
your change in voltage is just equal to
your current
times your resistance and so this is
going to be your current is going to be
amperes
times your resistance is 2 ohms
times 2 ohms which is going to be equal
to
8.0 volts
and so if the voltage difference between
that point and that point is 24 volts
which we know from this voltage source
but if we drop eight volts as we go to
this point well then the difference
between this point and this point or
this point and this point right over
here
this has got to be a 16 volt drop
if our delta v across the 6 ohm resistor
is equal to
16 volts well then we can use ohm's law
again to figure out i2
i sub 2 is going to be equal to our drop
in voltage
so 16 volts divided by this resistance
6 ohms and so what is this going to be
equal to 16 divided by 6 is 2 and 4 6 or
2 and two-thirds or
2.66666 and if we round to two
significant digits you're going to have
2.7
amps and so we just figured out what we
wanted to figure out this right over
here is 2.7
amps or 2.7 amperes but we can keep
analyzing it for fun i encourage you to
figure out what that current is now the
current i sub 3 and use the exact same
technique and one thing that you should
feel very comfortable of is that this
current that is flowing through the
first resistor that 4 ampere current
that current gets split between i2 and
i3 and so i2 and i3 should add up to the
original 4 amps so just thinking about
it that way if you do the same type of
analysis we just did you should get 1.3
amps for i3 because 2.7 plus 1.3 is
going to be equal to 4 amps